The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAL: Hi.
I'm Sal.
Today, we're going to solve
problem nine of fall 2009, the
final for 3091.
The problem reads, the phase
diagram of the binary system
neodymium, praseodymium and
EPR is given below.
There are two allotropes--
alpha, which is hexagonal
close pack--
HCP--
and beta, which is body
center cubic--
BCC.
Now this problem obviously is
about phase diagrams. So
before you attempt to solve the
problem, you need to make
sure that you understand how
to read phase diagrams and
also how to apply the lever
rule and know where in the
phase diagram to apply
the lever rule.
So if we look at our phase
diagram, which I have drawn
over here for part A--
the part A asks, explain why a
lenticular phase diagram is to
be expected for the
binary system.
So this is a lenticular phase
diagram and a lot of students
when answering this problem
get confused and say, oh,
because the components are
soluble together, that's why
you get a lenticular.
That's correct, but that
information you can get from
the phase diagram.
It's obvious by looking that you
have an alpha phase that
you have from zero to a 100%
that can be missable together,
but it doesn't really
explain the answer.
Now the best thing to do is to
look at the periodic table of
elements and look at the
physical and chemical
properties of the elements.
So here we're comparing to--
we're comparing neodymium and
praseodymium, which are
two components that
are making the alloy.
So here this is atomic percent
praseodymium on your x axis
and on your y axis, you have
temperature in degrees Celsius.
So at zero percent praseodymium,
we have a 100%
neodymium and at 100%
praseodymium, we have zero
percent neodymium.
That pretty much comes from
the phase diagram.
So why would these
two have formed a
lenticular phase diagram?
Well, if you look at the
periodic table, you'll notice
that these two elements lie
right next to each other.
So what does that mean?
That means that chemically,
they're pretty
much almost the same.
To answer this question for part
A, I would look at it and
I would notice that actually
both these elements have the
same crystal structure.
So I would write down,
they have the
same crystal structure.
They also have pretty much the
same electronegativity or very
similar electronegativity.
So very similar
electronegativity.
Also, they have pretty
much the same atomic
radii--atomic radius.
And also very similar, very
close to each other--
the same density.
So the density is
almost the same.
So because these two components
have the same
properties together-- the same
size, same crystal structure,
then you should expect that they
should form a missable
lenticular phase diagram, which
is what we have here.
So if you were to answer that
for part A, that would give
you pretty much all the points
and that hints that you
understand how to look at the
chemical properties of the
elements and the physical
properties of the elements and
compare them together and
rationalize why the phase
diagram looks the way it does.
Part B asks--
I'll come over here
to do part B.
At each point, I identify all
the phases present in
equilibrium.
II--
state the composition of
each phase and III--
calculate the relative amount
of all phase presence.
And it asks us to analyze the
three points that we have on
our phase diagram.
So we have one for
I, II, III--
So number one-- if we look at
our phase diagram, we lie
exactly where your
alpha phase is.
So to answer the first part of
the problem is identify all
the phases present--
we only have the alpha
phase here.
So if you were to write down
alpha phase, that's correct.
The part two says, state the
composition of each phase.
So what's the composition of
the alpha phase in here?
Well, if I trace down my line
down to my x axis, I notice
that for the atomic percent
of praseodymium, pretty
close to about 18%.
So it's 18 atomic
percent here.
So to answer the question for
part I, I would notice that--
I would write down that
it's alpha phase.
For the second part,
we have 18%--
18 atomic percent praseodymium,
which leaves
behind about 82% atomic
percent of neodymium.
And for part three--
part three asks about
the relative amounts
of the phases present--
we only have the alpha phase
in that part so I would say
that we have 100% pure
alpha, which is--
if you write this,
that's correct.
Now for the second point that
we're going to analyze in our
phase diagram number two--
if we come over here and look at
it, you'll notice that now
we lie in between or between
two phases so where the
lenticular region is at.
So here, I don't have pure
beta or pure liquid.
I have a combination of both
beta and liquid and this is
exactly where you need to
apply the lever rule.
You can't apply the lever rule
here because it's just 100%
pure phase.
You can only apply when you're
in a region where you have two
phases that coexist
in equilibrium.
So if I go ahead and
analyze part two--
part I--
the phases that are present are
beta and the liquid phase.
For part II, it asks, what
are the compositions?
Well, if I blow up my lenticular
phase diagram--
so I'm sitting right here and
this is sitting at around 62
two atomic percent of Pr--
praseodymium and it asks about
the phases or the relative
composition of each phase.
Well, over here, I have beta,
over here I have the liquid
phase and in between I have the
beta plus the liquid that
are coexisting in equilibrium.
So if I want to know
how much--
what's the composition of my
beta phase that I have here--
well, I'm going to have to
go to the line where both
intersect with the beta and
the beta plus liquid
intersects.
And if I analyze this point--
if I look down what the
composition of that is for
that line, I see that I have
about 56 atomic percent of
praseodymium.
So to start answering part two,
I would say that if I
look at beta--
in the beta phase, I have 56% or
atomic percent of Pr and if
I have 56% of Pr, then this
leaves just 44 atomic percent
of neodymium and if I
look at my liquid--
so I'm going to just move
this over here.
I look at the liquid, which
is going to be where it
intersects in the liquid region
and if I trace it down,
I see that this is
about 70% or so.
So here I have around
roughly 70%.
If you trace it down to your x
axis, this is 70% or 70 atomic
percent Pr, which leaves 30
atomic percent of neodymium.
So if you were to write this
down for the liquid, just
write an arrow here so I won't
have to rewrite that--
that would be the answer for
part two because again, we're
analyzing this point, which is
point number two and we're in
between two phases.
So that covers the second
part of part B.
And for the third part--
I'll go ahead and I'll
put up here.
That one now is where we have
to apply the lever rule
because now we have to figure
out exactly how much of each
phase is present
at equilibrium.
So if I look at my diagram, it's
going to be very simple.
If I want to know how much beta
I have in this mixture,
you're simply going to apply the
lever rule and for beta,
it's going to be whatever this
magnitude is or whatever the
difference between these two
points are over the length of
the whole existence at that
temperature of the length of
the whole composition that you
have. So if I do the simple
calculation for beta--
beta is going to be simply 70
minus 62 over 70 minus 56 and
this essentially just equals
eight over 14, which is about
57 atomic percent
praseodymium.
So--
sorry-- not percent Pr--
percent beta phase.
So in beta, I have 57%.
So that means that
for my liquid--
I can do two things for this
problem, for the liquid.
I know that everything is
normalized to 100%.
So the difference between 157
will be the liquid composition
where I can go ahead and
apply the lever rule
again and do the math.
So if I apply the lever rule
again for my liquid phase,
it's going to simply
be 62 minus 56.
We're coming back on our--
looking at the liquid phase
that is coexisting in this
equilibrium at this temperature
and I want to know
how much liquid--
it's going to be the magnitude
of this over the total length
of my composition there--
that's what I'm doing here.
Again, this is 70 minus 56.
So this would end up being just
six over 14, which is
essentially just--
if you have 57% here, if you do
the math, you're going to
get 43% of liquid.
So part three--
when you apply the lever rule,
you see that at this point you
have more beta than
you have liquid--
and it kind of makes sense
because if you look at your
diagram, your point is sitting
closer to the beta phase.
So I would expect intuitively
that I would have more beta
present then the liquid present
and that's exactly
what the lever rule tells us.
So that's point number
two for part B.
And if I look at point number
three now, which I'll write
right here--
this is essentially the same
thing as point number one.
But now point number three--
we're no longer lying
in alpha.
We're lying in the beta phase.
So if I trace down what my
composition is here, I'm about
78% of Pr--
so to answer the
first part I--
beta--
the second part II, which is
dealing with the compositions
of that beta phase is going to
be 78% or 78 atomic percent Pr
and that leaves just 22 atomic
percent neodymium--
and for the third part III--
what is the relative amounts
of the phases present?
Not the composition,
the phases.
I'm exactly where only pure beta
exists so I can say that
I have 100% beta.
So that pretty much does
it for this problem.
Again, knowing how to read phase
diagrams, knowing how to
apply the lever rule and where
to apply the lever rule will
allow you to very easily
solve the problem.
A lot of students make the
mistake of trying to apply the
lever rule when you
have a pure phase.
I mean, that makes no sense
because said lever rule pretty
much calculates what fraction
of the phases are present in
that equilibrium mixture.
So keep in mind that you can
only do that when you have a
region in your phase diagram,
when you have two phases that
are coexistant in equilibrium.